[Musique]
j'étais des voiries complètement par les
punaises toute la nuit je me suis levé
1,6 je suis obligé de dormir pendant une
heure sur une chaise avec une couverture
et puis j'étais tellement fatigué j'ai
été obligé de me coucher sur le lit
peine punaises avec une couleur tire
autour de moi parce que les chambres de
bonnes sont très recherchés actuellement
très recherchés
hélas nous sommes souvent des
propriétaires qui veulent pas jouer leur
chambre ou à ce qui ne facilite pas
d'âge pour
allez leur chant et pour des raisons
pour des raisons diverses
bien souvent il dit préfère garder leurs
chambres vides et fermé plus tôt que de
la louer évidemment ça augmente les
difficultés commencent et vous torturer
les chambres de code ou principe on
passait des annonces sur les journaux
demandant propriétaire
leur chambre et cette manière qu'on
arrive à en recevoir quelques unes et
qu'est-ce qui les demandent
en particulier c'est surtout le milieu
étudiant qui recherchent la légende qui
arrive à paris
sans logement des gens peu argentés
recherche
bien souvent aussi c'est des jeunes et
qui s'apprête à se marier qui l'amitié
des fleurs parents évidemment il démarre
dans une vie nouvelle qui le mariage et
recherche à ce moment-là logements entre
cher ses chambres de bonnes
seul ou pas cher selon les quartiers
c'est variable principe entre 150 et 300
oui chercher une chambre de break et peu
importe quartier j'ai 15 m2 7e 15e 7e
14e se situe c'est tout on voulait
absolument le quartier là vers vitry
parra n'ont pas spécialement dans le sud
je travaille à villejuif j'avais fait un
disque diam ça m'intéresserait pas ce
que ça entre le trajet et vous voulez et
quelle serait votre votre loyer par an
jusqu'à l' sur votre loyer c'est un peu
la petite chambre une chambre de bonne
je m'aime mais une chambre meublée avec
le coin avec l'eau courante à
l'intérieur c'est combien à plombs près
la chambre et et il n'ya vous si vous
voulez une chambre avec un petit côté
cuisine oui bon ou alors la chambre
c'est assez grande de quoi faire à
manger dedans moi je ne sais bien mais
c'est ça une chambre avec un coin
cuisine il commenté entre 250 et 300
mais c'est à dire entre 25 et 30 mille
francs annoncés il ya aussi le justement
c'est justement pour diderot prix c'est
dans mes prix 12 e
elle est indépendante ya l'eau sont pas
bien où je suis allemande je suis enfin
cherche une chambrée chercher du travail
du travail à paris travaille c'est sûr
que oui bien sûr paris ça ne pose pas de
problème qu'elle serait la somme que
vous savourez votre
mier tamil par mois par mois et vous
faites de la cuisine monsieur fait un
peu de paix c'est juste le soir jusque
là ce soir là 186 g particulier porté
que entre vous êtes chez vous
entièrement chez vous en faites ce que
vous voulez et vous en avez plusieurs
140 80 ans je suis obligé de les en
cause et à ma mère qui paye mes chansons
pop à l'hectare
ça dépend très souvent hélas en vain
véritablement insalubres
d'entrée la brème et
les gens se trouvant à la rue ils sont
obligés de prendre cela plutôt que je
les pensais bien souvent des gens se
plaignent qu'il ya des présences de
contrôle à de cafard même de rassasier
à ce moment-là il s'adresse mais souvent
nous pour essayer de retrouver autre
chose nous efforçons de faire toujours
mieux voulais l'annoncer dans ce cas là
bas il ya deux cas exposé soit qui sont
remboursés et qui se trouve quelque
chose pas aux moyens ce que nous les
rôles aux gens quand on a la possibilité
malgré le risque de punaises malgré la
promiscuité et le manque de confort les
chambres de bonnes trouve toujours
beaucoup d'amateurs les agences ne
peuvent évidemment pas satisfaire toutes
les demandes
mais en cherchant bien et avec un peu de
chance on finit par trouver quand même
et vous comment avez vous fait pour
trouver votre chambre de bonne
vous êtes passé par l' agence non pas
par une agence j'ai pu avoir cela par la
population c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'ailleurs les biens c'est aussi vous
voulez vous avez le confort c'est
beaucoup dire mais
angers modifier l'aspect de la chambre
et je pense que c'est un peu aussi le
reflet de sa façon de vivre je crois que
fond
on peut alors penser qu'on est
malheureux selon l'attitude de la
chambre j'aime aussi la chambre de bonne
parce que tous les objets se retrouvent
se rassemblent avec les idées sont elles
sont toutes là vous avez l'eau non à 12
sur le tas les enfants je m'arrête
lorsqu'on est jeune mais c'est très
possible de faire d'autrefois un étage
par jour presque chercher de l'eau vous
allez où il a cherché à les tâches du
tout c'est le dilemme 6e
le fait de nous chauffeur livreur mais
vous êtes artiste
oui un peu artiste aussi gsm dans la
chanson je ne sais pas ça explique tous
les artistes faveur les chambres de
bonnes
oui parce que la chambre de bonne si
c'est si vraiment on retrouve tout le
confort moral si vous voulez parce que
toute l'allée point ces vieilles ne se
joindre meubles au lit
enfin tu oublies tout s'est réglé dans
une seule pièce et c'est formidable je
crois le confort moral vous suffit
seulement elle est chère cette chambre
noël pas cher mais c'est vraiment aux
7500 invisible romain c'est vraiment
très très rare on vous avez loïs et non
sur le fond est que vous êtes chaud
froid
oui je paie mon électricité enfin j'ai
fait la cuisine s'est joué après son
propos souvent je fais la cuisine quand
je prends vraiment un sport me considère
pas ça pour changer un peu
moi je fais la cuisine c'est très limité
nos assiettes en plastique des petits
bols et le voisin
du voisin savin enfin ils sont pas trop
maniaque et pensées sont jeunes ils sont
comme moi ils travaillent ils s'amusent
au même rythme que moi seulement de
temps en temps il ya une dame qui vient
habiter là similaire mais qui est très
riche qui habitent en province et qui
sont petit pied-à-terre dans une de ses
chambres
si on est à l'abri d'une chambre de
bonne oui enfin elle n'habite pas elle
est là le toute l'année pour l'avoir ici
à paris compétent m
on va y ajouter la touche un manteau
alors les gentilles mais seulement elle
et c'est pas dieu zay avec passion
en guinée c'est ça c'est là que c'est
bien compliqué parce que on le fait
toute l'année évidemment on peut pas
travailler alors à ces cas parce qu'elle
l'est dans ma cachette voit l'armée une
musique assez forte pour qu'elle vous
donne pas le bruit la brosse à dents fin
nous savons pourquoi avoir deux heures
trop parce que c'est pour le pen quoi la
nuit alors c'est seul ennui oui mais le
manceau charles de confortables vous
êtes bien oui sur deux oui ça va je suis
habitué et puis des évidemment si
j'étais plus vient j'aimerais essayer de
pas avoir de robinet de lavabo douche
quel est votre budget mensuel des
pensées convergent tournoi je sais pas
exactement cette année scolaire la gt
boursière japonaise ours et puis je
faisais des petits travaux verdienne
cent jeudi j'ai très peur que tout le
monde fait puni par an donne un peu
d'argent en temps s'accélère au parent
ne pouvez pas vous aider pour tous les
échanges plus confortable
d'abord c'est difficile à trouver
ensuite les chambres confortables c'est
très cher
ensuite il faut que le jeu de même les
bras
et puis enfin faisait gérer quoi je vais
pas réalisé à leurs deux mondes feliz
homophobes sur le ton plus que dans
cinquante ans quand même il faut bien
qu'ils vivent une vie normale mais vaut
pas est en train de penser à leurs
enfants jusqu'à trente ans jusqu'à
persistant et dans les constructions
neuves
le sinistre escaliers de service
n'existe plus les chambres de bonnes
baptisé aujourd'hui chambre de service
se trouve souvent au premier étage
elles sont claires et pourvue de tout le
confort moderne mais mais mais
même si c'est
pour en trouver une il suffit de
rencontrer un propriétaire qui sachant
faire sans lui tout seul veuille bien
loué la chambre destinée à son
domestique
[Musique]